good morning yes Feliz Cinco de Mayo you
guys I'm here with Leticia Mitchell Chef
Leticia Mitchell we got I got my she
supplied me with the reboso my shawl
right here thank you very much
thank you for making up with waking up
with us this morning okay you guys it
may be 5 a.m but we don't care we're
making margaritas in a little bit it
doesn't matter but first off Leticia it
is your first well at least for the
downtown location the first cinco de
mayo party what people expect oh my
goodness from five to eleven we're gonna
have live entertainment an amazing stage
but outside we have tables and chairs
tents and a bar of course so you're
gonna have from bailables Banda you know
great groups and um DJs so it's gonna be
just fantastic giveaways tequila girls
you know Margaritas cervezas everything
everything yeah five dollar Mark uh
tequila shots I saw there too yeah also
speaking of tequila guess what's in here
you guys our Margarita say okay so I'm
gonna do this one-handed okay
[Applause]
[Music]
let me hit it mine so I have a classic
ladies a fresh here yeah
watermelon one just pour it right in
here we go here we go
okay and stop
strong I'll go buy Taki and ran right
here
we'll see you today
[Music]